habits that have made me the most funny
waking up at 4 a.m and that is enabled
by going to bed consistently at the same
time on weekdays and weekends from like
four o'clock to nine o'clock is like my
time and that's where i really move the
big projects that are gonna make massive
impact in the business what about like
concerts and like going out with people
there's a reason really high-level
entrepreneurs live the way they do it is
a choice i choose that life you don't
have to choose that just understand like
that's your trade-off and for me going
out to dinner at 7 30 on friday is not
important to me all of my friends who
are here in austin know that they're
gonna go out with alex and layla we're
going to dinner at 5 45 so that we like
get there receded we're eating by 6 15
and we can leave by seven drive home by
7 30 and then we can wind down they know
that going into it it's just like if you
don't want to play that then like that's
cool that it means that like our
relationship isn't valuable enough for
you to eat dinner earlier and that's
fine most people are game to do that and
they're like you know it's so nice being
able to get back at eight and like not
ruin your routine i'm like yeah it's
awesome that's why we do